[Music]
I feel like my undergraduate students
who are you know 18 to 22 years old are
maybe a bit more cynical about social
media and their smartphones and all then
we would have expected I mean they're
cynical about everything on a certain
level but I think that they're they're
less likely to get hooked into some
crazy idea and start following some
conspiracy about George Soros or gun
ownership or whatever you know those
kinds of tunnels then most adults and
partly it's because they're CUNY
students and they don't have time
they're working they're theirs they're
stuck and and that forces them to be
grounded on a certain level that said
this is the way they date you know what
they're swiping left and right on faces
and all and they're they're definitely
products of the digital media
environment in the way that they have
real yes or no thumbs up thumbs down
like or not like relationships to things
you know the the I feel like that in
between place is really hard for them to
inhabit and that's the place that I grew
up living for you know that strange
please place of like what is David Lynch
mean in this scene what the heck is
going on here that I live for that I
live for that weird uncertainty that to
be in an optical illusion and you know
where am i and that's not that's not a
place that I see them striving for
yearning for you know I see a there's
such a rush there's such a time come
rushon that their main experience of
media which seems to be digitally
induced is how long do I have to look at
this before I can dismiss it how do I
wipe it away so you don't read a
magazine to get into the magazine you
read a magazine okay I don't need that I
don't don't you're not done and then you
can move on to the next thing and that's
when there's that there isn't that sense
of of reveling you know the the digital
future I imagined look more like Rick
link letters movie slacker where oh
because I have the internet I could get
really into William Burroughs and Brion
Gysin and Genesis P Orage and find weird
cult II groups and get more slack not
less slack because I was able to type my
paper on a Commodore 64 instead of
sitting there on my smith-corona I have
more time to veg out or to get stoned or
to be weird and it didn't happen like
that we didn't get the cognitive surplus
that clay sure he told us about instead
they just filled it with more and more
and more and more stuff so that there's
a kind of a franticness and a
hurriedness that I don't remember us
having at 18 to 22
[Music]